David so was telling me about a time
that you guys went to a movie premiere
or something and then they were like
Chinese opening credits and then you
yelled out I can't read this [__] we're
watching this Jackie Chan movie and a
bunch of Chinese letters come down right
out of nowhere Joe's sitting next to me
man I can't read that [__] [__]
do you remember that I just used to talk
whatever was on my mind because I looked
at his face and he wasn't making a joke
funny thing is I saw that part of the
podcast I texted David right away I was
like you know what's funnier day videos
what I was like you didn't know Joe back
then so you thought Joe says I can't
read this [__] because it's Chinese I
know Joe and the reason why he said that
is he forgot his glasses but he's
blaming
we're being out of focus that's probably
more true that's way better that makes
way more sense why would I say that I of
course I can't read Chinese that would
be the stupidest thing to say I
denounced it immediately I don't know
any Japs thanks